- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
- [Male] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Charles Kennel] I am in fact literally
the bridge between the past and the future
in many different ways. This is the title
that I originally chose when I submitted
my first abstract. When I got to preparing
it I thought I would try something new
with the same material that I have been
working on for some time. So I've
re-changed the name now and that will be
"Of a Climate Regime Change." It's the
same material basically but the hypothesis
is that we may be with our modern
instrumentation over the last 20 or so
years, we may be seeing a change in
climate that is something like those that
might have caused Jeff Severinghaus'
abrupt transitions. I'm going to go
through it with you. It is of course a
very small version of very big events that
happened in the past. I first got
interested in this problem because of a
issue of public awareness and policy. The
public issue is called the paradox. The
triple hiatus paradox. If you cherry
picked your data as this article did, you
can find a time in 1997 and another time
in 2012 when the Earth's temperature was
the same that it had been. This led to the
idea that the globe is not warming even
though the carbon dioxide is increasing. I
began to ask myself two other questions,
"What else was going while the global
temperature was constant? Was climate
change also disappearing?" I found of
course two other paradoxes. "Why are the
extreme events in climate increasing?"
Here's the key I show, "Why is the Arctic
warming even more rapidly?" Let's first of
all verify that this is the hiatus. It
started in the year 2000. During that time
the carbon dioxide has increased and
humans have added about 27 percent more
CO2 than they have since the beginning of
the industrial revolution and this should
have lead to increase in the warming rate.
In climatologist language, four tenth of a
watt per meter. We were putting more
energy into climate but it wasn't turning
up in the global temperature. The question
was, "Where was that energy going?" Here's
a longer perspective on the hiatus. This
is a record since 1880 and it shows the
much shorter record than you've seen thus
far but it shows the global temperature
evolution. The first thing you notice is
that there was another hiatus about
between 45 and 75. They do happen. They
are features of climate models. They are
areas where the climate goes through a
reconfiguration. Our present hiatus
started with a bang. With a huge El Niño
in 1997 and 1998. My first year as
Director of Scripps when my office was
inundated. Then you can see the profile of
the slowing warming that we've seen
throughout the century. The global mean
temperature that the scientists calculate
is taken from data. Most of it is from
satellite observations of the sea surface
temperature and the sea covers 70 percent
of the Earth's surface. You would expect
that this computation will be dominated by
what's happening in the ocean. After many
gyrations the community came to realize
that it was the ocean. It's the behavior
of the ocean that was responsible for this
hiatus in warming because we knew from
earlier studies going back to the 1980s
that pacific ocean for example could
oscillate between two very extreme states
in which the temperature changes
dramatically. Do you notice that the El
Niño is a warm state and La Niña is a cool
state and so perhaps what was happening
was that we were switching from El Niño to
La Niña prevailing state thereof. Sorry I
have to tell you a little bit, just a
little bit about how the El Niño cycle
works. What you're looking at here is a
sketch taken from the pacific equator,
stretching from the East in Lima to the
West in Darwin. You'll see in the top, in
the La Niña phase, the Trade Winds push
the wavy ocean towards the West and
that water heats up from the sun as it
goes. As it heats up it expands a little
bit so the winds have to push the water up
stream, uphill. It goes until it can't go
any further so you'll get a deep water in
the Western pacific that's warm and then
this circulation pattern pushes up cold
water in the East. That's the cooling
phase of the La Niña. The El Niño is a
little bit different. The Trade Winds can
suddenly stop for some reason and all this
water rushes downhill. The warm water gets
heated the second time as it crosses the
pacific slosh up against the North
American and South American continents.
What happened? Did the Trade Winds
increase? Where if the right sense to
create an El Niño, a La Niña? The answer
is from this remarkably difficult data set
to compile, a hundred years of the Trade
Wind stress on the ocean water in the
Central Pacific. You can see it oscillated
around until about the year 2000 when it
switched from El Niño sense, smaller Trade
Wind, to La Niña sense, larger Trade Wind.
Is continuing to get larger in the
negative direction that's the negative
part of this curve and it's
unprecedentedly large and it is not
included at present in contemporary
present climate models. But the Trade Wind
has been exceptionally large. Which means
then you would think if that were the
case, that in fact you were driving a lot
of heat energy into the ocean in the
Western Pacific. Here is a picture of a
ocean heat content that was published just
about six or seven months ago in science.
But it looks like it solves the problem.
What Chen and Tang did was divide their
time that they looked at the data. From
before the hiatus on the right and after
the hiatus began on the left. You see two
plots. The bottom one is the one pertinent
to my argument about the El Niño and I'll
come to the top one in a moment. What you
see is a spread against longitude across
the Pacific. The red blob is the
distribution of ocean heat down to about
300 meters. You see this abrupt switch in
colors if you will. The same switch that
you saw in that earlier picture from Woods
Hole. What we do know is that at around
the time at the hiatus that Pacific ocean
state changed to a heat sequestering
state. But the other thing that happened
which actually took over after awhile
during this same period. Is displayed in
this plot on the left which is somewhat
different because it transect up the
Atlantic from South to North and it shows
you where new heat is being buried in the
North Atlantic. You can see basically that
the heat is being buried at pretty high
latitudes. This started at approximately
the same time. This little event here that
we are observing is a small version of the
events that Jeff Severinghaus was talking
about somewhat earlier where it was
possible to slow down the Atlantic
Meridian circulation. You can see the
strong different between the two states.
This change took place across the large El
Niño that started the process off. What
else was going on during this time? The
oceans would tell you this spread all
around the Earth's ocean. That tells you
right away that we're doing with a
comprehensive change in ocean state and
you would expect then that there would be
other changes in the climate that occurred
at the same time. Other parts of this
restructuring. As you've probably have
understood from the pictures of polar
bears, there actually is an Arctic regime
shift in progress. This is first revealed
by two formal assessments. One in 2005
that used primarily data from before the
hiatus began and another one only seven
years later. They discovered a major
change in the distribution of Arctic
heating. During the hiatus has been
fastest in Spring and Autumn and before it
was fastest in Winter which was consistent
with the earlier greenhouse warming
models. It's now faster over the oceans
and the land. These change in patterns
suggested to you that the Arctic developed
a new warming source that was not as
strong in the previous period. Satellite
data first began to be collected with
great accuracy later on sea ice area in
79. Here is the curve that you can see of
the minimum sea ice extent which occurs at
the end of the warm season in September.
As a function of time, September after
September since 1979. What you can infer
from this plot is a break in behavior in
which the sea ice was slowly declining but
oscillating about a slowly declining mean.
Suddenly there looks like a change in
state. Over this period of time, the sea
ice area has declined by about 40 percent
and the sea ice volume is down to 25
percent what it had been in 1979. Here is
the same data that was there in case the
movie didn't work. This shows you where
the timing of the sea ice decline. There's
one other thing that has happened during
the period of the hiatus which I think
will be interesting to Jeff and others.
It's a small analogue of the events that
slowed the meridional overturn in
circulation. During this hiatus and only
since about the year 2000, a new pattern
of winds developed over the Arctic ocean.
It's called the Arctic Dipole Anomaly.
This pair of winds going in opposite
directions drives ice and sea and fresh
water in the Arctic into the North
Atlantic where it will shut off or it can
impede. The word collides basically with
the Gulf Stream. At that collision point
the water sinks to depth. We did see that.
This is a small event of something that
actually happened in the historical record
8,000 years ago as the ice sheet was
retreating across North America. As it
retreated it left behind in the area of
Hudson Bay, a huge glacial lake that was
contained between the melting ice in one
hand and the moraine that had pushed up on
the front. These glacial moraines are
unstable and there was a huge outflow of
water that occurred all at once. There was
a 200 year period of cool climate that
then recovered. The Columbia River was
also formed this way. What the satellites
have observed is a great injection of
fresh water into this gyre here, Beaufort
Gyre, that began at approximately the same
time. That water is lighter and when it
gets to the saltier Atlantic, the saltier
Atlantic will sink. Here is the next and
most important point. This sea ice retreat
that I just documented is warming the
Arctic by a very simple mechanism. When
you replace white ice with blue ocean you
absorb much more solar energy. The sea ice
itself may reflect half back to space and
the ocean absorbs 93 percent of the energy
that's falling on it. As the sea ice
retreats it warms the Arctic. A recent
paper that came out from Scripps measured
the degree of warming since the satellite
era started in 79. They found that the net
sea ice retreat adds about six watts per
meter squared but two thirds of the
heating that took place in that period
occurred in the 10 years between 01 and
11. Arctic is small but if you average
this over the globe you get 0.21 watts per
meter squared. Which is about a quarter of
the increase that you would have expected
from the increase in greenhouse gas at
that time. You have added a new warming
mechanism that the climate at least in
recent times was not used to. This is a
picture of the geography of heat transport
in the climate. I put it on even though
it's complicated. Just to remind you that
the basic circulation of the atmosphere as
understood from the time of Edmond Halley
was it was heavy and strong warming of the
ocean and land over the tropics. This heat
was then transported to the North. It was
a North-South circulation. A North pole,
North equator to pole circulation that's
the fundamental feature of our climate
transport. If you suddenly add a new
energy, new heating source at the poles,
particularly the Arctic. Won't you change
the circulation of heat in the atmosphere
and will this not in fact lead to states
like the El Niño? What we do know and this
is a question still under active
investigation. What we do know is that we
have created a 17 or 18 year persistent La
Niña-like state in the Pacific Ocean and
also similar outflow on the North
Atlantic, that is lasting longer than most
typical La Niñas. Lasted the whole period
of time. What this have had an effect on
the climate down below. Because when
you're in a La Niña state, you bend the
jet stream as you see. You've seen many
many pictures recently. Anytime you look
at the weather you'll see the jet stream
dipping deep into Central United States.
We've remained in the state of La Niña
like jet stream. The weather patterns then
correlate with this. The question is
global temperature has been constant. You
would expect then that there would be very
many fewer heat waves right? Or at least
the same number as before. This is not
proven the case. Here's a remarkable data
analysis generated in Spain where they
were able to compile the mean Summer
temperature in Europe for the last 500
years since 1500. What you see is, 5 of
the 10 years in the 2010 were the hottest
years in the 2010 decade with the hottest
years on record. You also hear about this
unstable... You hear this bending La Niña
like jet stream. You hear about it in
other context because in the winter it
brings Arctic air to the South and is then
responsible for the large snow storms that
we've seen in the past. We also know that
the La Niña state implies a very dry
climate in California. Something that we
are presently observing. Here were the
questions. I phrased the hypothesis as a
set of questions. Did the Arctic warming
associated with the super-El Niño which
pushed the ice over the edge? Did it
trigger a continuing ice retreat when
Winter re-growth could not make up for the
previous year's loss? Did Arctic warming,
by altering the North-South heat flow...
Did it strengthen the Trade Winds, create
the La Niña bias and enable the persistent
ocean heat sequestration that we've been
seeing? Did it warming, by altering the
heat flow caused the observed pattern and
enhancement of extreme event occurrence?
Then finally, how long can this kind of
thing go on? Will the present dynamical,
quasi-equilibrium be maintained until the
energy added to the climate system from
ice and snow retreat stops? Thank you.